the Freedland reception center in lower
saxony
is the first taste of a new life for
many refugees I did nothing wrong our
children didn't support the regime we
lived in the heart of Damascus our house
was destroyed in 1945 most of the camp's
inhabitants were Germans including
returning soldiers ravaged by the war
their country had spread
they were half starved many were ill
today friedland is a reception camp for
asylum seeking migrants and refugees
they've all had traumatic experiences so
many massacres I lived in constant fear
you've lost track of who was killing
whom he lose sight of the truth in a DW
documentary about the camp refugees from
Syria Eritrea Afghanistan and Pakistan
share their stories along with Germans
who were among the first to live in the
camp such as Ana D kyon she arrived when
she was 8 when I meet children here
today I relive my own experience back
then I remember how broken everyone
looked they were sick and hungry but
there was this feeling that the worst
was over and people were safe
the Freedland reception center the name
means land of peace has harbored
refugees for 70 years you can see more
moving stories from then and now in the
DW documentary Freedland